all right james yeah sir james where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally
uh charleston west virginia
which is where you're still living today
yeah yes sir
you grew up right here on this in this
holler yeah i was born here
and tell me about your childhood you had
your mom and dad growing up as a kid
well when i was growing up i didn't have
no dad
and my mother had to keep us i had one
but he never would do anything for us
and we didn't have nothing uh we'd have
the toothache
and our face to swell up like that and
usually when there's a little snow on we
had to suffer all through that
and uh so we had a hard time
your family was poor yeah that's poor
and the only thing
we had to eat for breakfast would be
sugar
and biscuits made with soda and it would
stick to the roof of your mouth
you guys grew your own food yeah i grow
my own food
how far did you go in school uh probably
the
fourth grade or so after that you
started
working i worked yes
what kind of what kind of jobs have you
had i carried stone for stone masons
i carried cinder blocks i mixed the
mortar pushed concrete the wheelbarrow
one for the head the thingy
the hose you put it in with and uh
worked for the state for a dollar an
hour
you never uh mine never did coal mining
no
coal mine was more a little further
south my dad was a gold miner her dad
was a coal miner yeah and he was in
world war one
i got him buried with her how old are
you now huh how old are you
uh 79 79 born june 15 1942.
did you do any military time no never
did
and uh how many kids have you had
six six kids and you and your wife
raised them
my wife raised them and i raised them
and uh every one of them is dead
but one is that right
well drugs drugs yep oh wow
yeah this region has been hit hard by
drugs right yeah it's changed a lot
since you were
young but why do you think that is why
do you think appalachia has just
been taken over by drug addiction uh
well
i've never took a drug in my life but
everybody thought like i did there
wouldn't be no sales for them
i don't understand what's on their mind
yeah i've interviewed a lot of people
from this area and it seems to me like
there's nothing going on
everyone gets bored and they just look
for something to i stay bored too but i
don't get on drugs
good fight good fight i'm sorry about
your kids
i don't know what kind of i don't know
what kind of hole that drugs has got on
them
but they run around their legs swelled
up this big around
with abscesses on them and still looking
for for
for a fix and i told them i'd go to the
hospital with them
stay with them all night all day and do
everything i could to get them off of it
they wouldn't listen to me
and your wife the mother the mother of
your children is yeah she's a good woman
she stuck right with us fed us she was a
good manager
and we never went hungry i mean when i
was
working and
i think if you got a kid or a son or
something or a baby or something i think
you ought to keep it
that's my motive
and did you ever consider leaving this
area no
i mean it just seems like poverty is is
rampant here every everyone is poorer
than the next
yeah yeah but i i'm struck by how
nobody wants to leave yeah no nobody
wants to leave
why do you think that is it's certainly
a beautiful area well it's kind of funny
because i've had two or three friends of
mine that's old and was dying
it seemed like they always they lived
here years ago and they'd come up and
talk to me and i said well i haven't
seen you for 20 years he said yeah i
said i come up here to see you
wasn't two or three days so he's dead i
think everybody wants to come back
to where they was born before they die
if they can
what was the best time of your life uh
when i was young and didn't have no pain
now i suffer every day what kind of pain
you have i've got
rheumatoid arthritis i've got the
my back don't have no tissues between
the bones
uh my knees are shot
i'm just the pain all over
but do you have any regrets so do you
have any regrets
in your life yeah what's your biggest
regret
well i'm kind of afraid to say but
the way the society not everybody
there's a lot of fine people but
the state and the stuff treated me
treated me
i'm sorry they mistreated
they mistreated me the state has and
stuff in terms of what like
like uh
my son was died in prison
and he uh was on the fourth stage of
cancer lung cancer they let him
boyfriend die
they wouldn't take him to the doctor and
end up present up at mount olive
and they brought him down to charleston
memorial hospital and that
lady was feeding him ice cream she told
me i got there
15 minutes before he i mean after after
he died
i said i looked around to give him
another spoon ice cream and he was dead
and they'd keep a hound in me for these
taxes that i don't that i don't know
what do you what do you attribute the
fact that so many of your children
became addicts too what do you think was
the the cause of that
the headache well i mean what your
children got into drugs what do you
think i don't know what caused it
but the people the young people they
fooled around with was on drugs i think
that's uh
something's got to do with it i've
always taught my kids to respect the
other people
not throw with drugs because if you do
it'll ruin your life
and you can't even buy a loaf of bread
i know people like that now yeah and
this region seems to be so it's
drugs are so out of control yeah they're
completely out of control yeah
what do you think the future is of this
part of the country
try to get them people off of drugs
when a person's on drugs he don't think
that nothing for about nobody but the
drug
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life uh
be good to everybody watch what you're
what's what you're doing and be good be
a good person
and respect everybody
are you religious um
i'm religious yes very religious but i
don't bother
because you see that wind blowing out
there
that tree and leaves are moving
the winds are doing that and they can
turn the car over can it
but can you see it that's a miracle
within itself ain't it
something can turn the car when you
can't see it
your family has owned a lot of the
property up and down this this hauler
right
50 years you've let some other people
come and live here
yeah with me my wife has fit everybody
kids other people's kids all of our life
they come in there and go
but sometimes if it caused too much
trouble we'd have to tell them to go
so you your your you and your wife would
take care of the other we took care of
every kid and we
ever was you can ask anybody around here
and they'll tell you the same thing i'm
telling you
we fed them we never turned a man away
or a woman or a kid
hungry never
and if i didn't have the food in here
i'd go out there and pick up paper and
crawl to help them
that's what i believe in yeah i mean the
kindness that you give
that you show others i think probably
comes back to you in one way or another
doesn't it
yeah that's what i think a lot of people
don't understand
if you'd come here if you're hungry and
you're a good person
i'll help you and i'll feed you
but there's one thing that i won't
support and i won't help as a drug
addict
i mean i might help him go to the doctor
or something but that's it
yeah the drugs changes a person's
behavior drastically doesn't
did you feel helpless with your kids did
you feel helpless
watching your kids and their drug
their drug addictions did you feel did
you feel helpless
trying to trying to help your kids
completely help us they wouldn't listen
to you
they'd be so sick of walking around with
abscesses on them that big
and their legs swelled up like that and
still looking for a dope and
they went to the hospital because it
went to their heart
and the doctor told him i said he said
we're going to operate on you this time
they said if you go back on dope
that's it and they went back on dope and
they killed them all
after losing so much of your family you
still keep a positive attitude
every time
never done it i think ever i cry
your wife there's the kids
the pain kicks in you can't kill it
it's going to be hard for you to outlive
everyone else in your family
i wish i wish it would have been me it
went to her
you have grandkids sir do you have
grandkids yeah
anyone will help me do nothing
i have to do everything by myself
they're right
do you think these younger generations
are different than than your generation
lots of different you know what do you
see as being different well
back in the old times you got in the
garden and you worked
or you wouldn't eat through the winter
and if you had
if you thought you was going to starve
you'd go to work the garden
yeah i mean appalachia is a very real
struggle to survive especially for your
when you the way you grew up
yeah and it's almost like that struggle
makes you
it puts your head and heart in the right
place it puts your heart yeah you're
right and life has become so easy for so
many people that they take it for
granted and
they drift off they've got it too easy
yeah people with people eat too much
they got it too good
the difference between your generation
and the younger generation is so
distinct
especially here even when i eat my
breakfast i go out and try to work
and pay for it
and you're remarkably healthy for your
age
i saw you on the pogo stick up in the
street just a little while ago
and you just keep it i keep it telling i
said i ain't dead yet but
you move around like you're 25 years old
what do you uh
what would you attribute that to why do
you think you're so
healthy mentally and physically well
here's what i think
you take a person that they say i'm
retired
and i don't think i think i on account
of that i hadn't aged any
and it's what i think well you think
you're young yeah i think i'm young
yeah so if you think you're young you
you're gonna do and you're gonna act and
behave as if you're young
i think everything closed down but i'm
getting there but it's taking us time
all right james well thank you so much
for sharing your story you're welcome i
wish you the best of luck i hope you
live a
nice long life thank you very much thank
you very much
and i love y'all i love you too
you're amazing
you